parmi les annonces de sam son côté fait
à quelques jours il ya eu notamment des
écouteurs des écouteurs ses écouteurs ce
sont les galaxies bugs pro buzz deux
pros buzz 2002 avant le procès ça les
galaxies bugs de pro et ses galaxies
buzz de propre et vient de succéder au
galaxy s pro jusque là je crois je vous
apprends absolument rien sauf que est-ce
que la copie est réussie est ce qu il
faut bien les acheter si vous avez
acheté ou si vous voulez acheter un
smartphone de samsung en 2022 peut-être
faut-il se poser la question de l'audio
et de venir acheter l'équipement qui va
bien complet c'est-à-dire une démontre
celle là c'est la ouate cinq
professionnels on en parle dans quelques
jours donc venez vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas les écouteurs est
ce qu'il est faux alors autant je vous
ai fait une vidéo il n'y a pas longtemps
pour vous parle des différents écouteurs
effet les golf pro j'avais bien aimé
autant ces buzz deux pros sont ils à la
hauteur sont ils intéressants faut-il se
positionner quels sont les avantages
qu'elles sont aussi les inconvénients
l'application est elle bien la réduction
brouille est elle bonne on va regarder
ça vous êtes prêts c'est parti
ah c'était 1 c'est parti un peu mou
c'est parti à l'aîné le loup c'est parti
c'est un petit peu bourrin allez on s'y
fait ça c'est le nouveau elle flippe 4
qui est également annoncée je m'amuse le
test donc je vous en donne mon retour
d'ici quelques jours donc revenait d'ici
quelques jours comme ça vous serez
toujours ce smartphone également sur la
montre également sur le z folle de 4
également sans plein de trucs donc à
plein de choses et plein de voter mais
là je voulais vraiment qu'on se
concentre aujourd'hui sur celui la
galaxie buzz de pros alors laboual c'est
très simple très sommaires ont pas passé
à des heures dessus je vous montre quand
même très rapidement si ça vous
intéresse et si j'y arrive il ya des
fois j ai je pas salir ses bottes sais
pas pourquoi il ya certaines boîtes on
les ou facilement il y en a d'autres il
faut passer des heures à s'acharner
dessus alors on va retrouver à
l'intérieur ici petit à manuel guide de
démarrage rapide vous allez avoir la
carte de garantie ok je ferai pas
l'affront de vous montrer ça là vous
avez un petit câble de chargement alors
sur les écouteurs vous n'avez jamais de
blocs de chasse pour utiliser le doc de
charge de votre smartphone ou alors vous
le brancher directement sur un
ordinateur pour venir le charger
directement usb c'est d'un côté et de
l'autre il a vous avez différents
embouts pour venir les régler à votre
taille donc voyez ici n'ont pas inventé
la poudre fond des choses qu'on
connaissait déjà voyez vous avez en tout
trois tailles d'embouts différentes
voilà pour la boîte le format de l'étui
est exactement le même c'est-à-dire à un
petit comment est ce qu'on peut appeler
ça un petit étui dans lequel on
viendrait mettre une bague presse pour
demander en mariage si vous êtes
romantique que ça peut vous faire penser
à ça vous avez donc votre petit étui
avec vos buzz à l'intérieur vous avez
une petite diode qui vous informe des
biens la charge des compagnies siess à
vouloir charger derrière ici en usb
c'est et puis voilà on a à peu près le
tour est léa seydoux ça laisse un poste
5 1 en main donc bon voilà y'a pas un
confort pas de problème là-dessus les
petits bugs quant à elle vient de se
positionner sont aimantés et vous avez
une petite diode qui vous informe
lorsqu'ils sont en charge voyez hop là
je prends jean lève sa détente jeux les
positionne elle s'allume comme ça vous
savez tous les buzz alors le confort
déjà ses trucs et très important alors
avant de vous parler du confort je
montre très rapidement vous avez trois
micros trois micros aussi qui serviront
pour la réduction de bruit qui serviront
pour les abeilles pour pas mal de choses
qui sont positionnés tout autour et à
l'intérieur
on va regarder si une fois de plus le
résultat est là vous avez petits
capteurs présents cela pour savoir s'ils
ont la mission l'a enlevé ça c'est pour
le rechargement et les micros ici plus
de petit embout donc les bugs sont des
besaces et standards rien de bien neuf
le truc qui est intéressant c'est que
samsung ici nous annonce des buzz 15%
plus petit que la génération précédente
un peu moins gros donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait quand on fait ça hop on vit à
zoomer on se positionne on prend là et
on le tourne un peu dans l'intérieur
voilà là il est bien positionnée pareil
quand son petit frère pour le prend et
hop on vient le tourner et le twist est
à l'intérieur alors une fois que vous
avez la bonne taille et bien vos buzz
ils sont bien positionnés alors il bouge
pas trop très honnêtement je suis pas
les pogos t je ne suis pas fait un
festival de métal avec donc je vais pas
vous donner de retour là dessus bonne
position bon confort ça ça me convient
plutôt bien réduction de bruit déjà pas
si les stagiaires ce que ça vient vous
boucher les oreilles est ce que ça vaut
couple un petit peu du bruit de
l'extérieur un petit peu ça fait le taff
ça fait un peu bouchons d'oreilles donc
là dessus ça me va bien le confort et
bien les embouts pour moi les embouts de
base sont à ma taille donc ils vont bien
aussi écrié cdbl ce qu'ils sont quand
même assez légers ils font 5,5 g par
butt bon ben voilà bon confort le rien
de particulier à venir vous signalez là
dessus on n'a pas de problématique d'un
confort ok ça fonctionne maintenant est
ce qui nous intéresse c'est la qualité
audio la qualité sonore alors qu'est-ce
qui est venu faire ici samsung samsung à
kg ça me sauve et rachetée à kg il ya
quelques années à kg c'est aujourd'hui
la signature audio de samsung et qui est
une référence dans le domaine alors que
nous on fait plusieurs trucs ici on nous
annonce une qualité hi-fi alors est pas
non plus énervé intention n'est pas sûr
là il fit au top top qualité comme sûr
si on avait un casque hi-fi à 2000 balle
c'est pas l'idée attention ça marche
néanmoins très très bien ici on a un son
24 bits alors 24 bits ça va faire quoi
par rapport à du 16 bits un peu plus
standard et bien ça va venir apporter
plus d'informations dans le signale donc
ça nous apportera un son qui va être un
peu plus riches ça c'est le premier
point le deuxième point c'est le codec
ici c'est le samsung seamless codec le
ssm vous venir trouver ici codec signé
samsung qui va venir apporter cette
expérience audio de qualité en tout cas
signé samsung c'est ce qu'on vient nous
promettre ici en tout cas on donne ici
deux cent cinquante six fois plus de
données traitées par rapport à la
génération précédente en plus de ça vous
avez ici deux haut parleurs d'eau
parlant directement par buzz son des
haut-parleurs coaxiaux vous avez
parmesan ou faire de 10 être et un
tweeter de 5,3 mm vous avez donc deux
canaux alors qu'est ce que ça vient
apporter le fait d'avoir deux canaux et
bien c'est tout simplement à fait
devenir séparer les graves d'un côté des
aigus de l'autre vous avez pas un seul
haut-parleur qui va travailler qui en
même temps va faire et les graves et les
aigus là ça permet de distinguer avec
ces deux voix vous avez le woofer qui va
travailler pour le signal médium grave
grave et puis je vais pas dire des
infrabasses qu'on est quand même sur des
intra donc on va venir se calmer et de
l'autre côté vous avez les médiums
médiums aigus aiguë qui vont être faits
par le twitter donc ça permet vraiment
de scinder ces signaux et devenir
optimiser la réponse sonore que vous
allez vous avoir directement dans vos
oreilles alors tout ça mis bout à bout
le 24 bits le codec de samsung et c'est
deux canaux et là ça marche patronale ça
fonctionne plutôt bien alors pour autant
j'ai trouvé aucune information sur
différents codecs de qualcomm à pts et
compagnie je n'ai pas vu donc a priori
ici il y en aurait pas pour autant j'ai
pas demandé la formation samsung mais il
ne semble pas qu'il y en des risques
même prudent ici que son collègue de
samsung mais je reste prudent alors
l'expérience tel quel et en audio elle
est bonne elle est de bonne qualité je
trouve que on a des graves qui sont
quand même relativement profond qui
marche d'ailleurs je veux venir nuance
et tout ça dans quelques instants
notamment avec la réduction brute qui
vient manger un peu sonné chez vous
expliquer c'est dans quelques secondes
moi j'ai bien aimé l'expérience si vous
restez sur une réduction de bruit coupé
vous restez sur un mode normal ou on
désactive l'électronique vous avez des
graves qui sont présents vous avez de
beaux grave qui viennent vraiment
ronronner on a pour autant des médiums
de bonne qualité on a un peu de matière
si vous voulez moi c'est vraiment une
image que j'ai pour ce que j'aime les
yeux j'écoute de la musique au casque
jet j'arrive à retrouver la matière la
matière des médiums un certain grain
pour moi dans ma tête en tout cas
ressort vraiment comme étant une matière
que je pourrai sentir et toucher j'ai
vraiment ces médiums un peu granuleux
que j'arrive à sentir et à percevoir et
pour autant des élus qui sont assez
clair que je vais venir retrouver sur un
tambourin sur une cymbale et même sur
une voie ça vient les larges vient donc
j'ai vraiment toutes ses sensations
audio que je vais retrouver ici ça ça me
convient plutôt bien alors ça c'est bien
lorsque je suis sur une réduction de
bruit qui est coupée maintenant lorsque
je viens activer la réduction de bruit
donc la réduction de bruit active qui
fait le taff plutôt pas mal elle n'est
pas aussi bonne que ce que j'ai pu
retrouver ailleurs sur certains autres à
mais je trouve quand même vraiment bien
il fait bien taf eh bien je trouve ça
bien manger un petit peu de son ca de
toute façon c'est la base l'électronique
vous venez l'activé directement sur des
buzz sur un casque sur ce que vous
voulez savoir bouffe un peu son ca me
mange un peu de médium et ça me donne
l'impression d'avoir un son un poil plus
étouffé un peu plus de grave mais malgré
tout le tas fait bien fait alors on peut
venir compenser grâce à un équaliseur
qu'on a ici à l'intérieur ça donne une
sensation des fois où on peut venir un
peut moduler les choses c'est pas de la
magie le son reste quand même de bonne
qualité même avec la réduction de bruit
active mais si on veut vraiment profité
de la bonne expérience et de la
meilleure expérience on ne désactive la
réduction de bruit on reste sur un mode
réduction de bruit et un ton n'est pas
de votre transparence mais rien et c'est
là que vous aurez vraiment la meilleure
expérience audio pour autant et je vous
le dis une fois de plus si vous activez
la réduction de bruit vous aura quand
même un son de bonne qualité qui
fonctionnera bien même si on est un peu
en dessous alors la réduction brute et
puisqu'on en parle alors on va seul à
remettre un petit peu il ya une appli et
je vous la montre dans quelques instants
à la traduction brûle fonctionne plutôt
pas mal elle va filtrer 40% du bruit
environnant c'est ce que nous annonce en
tout cas ici ça le seconde alors moi
j'ai pas mesurer l'écart ont pourtant du
bruit environnant je trouve que c'est
vrai que ces buzz viennent car il
coupait un petit peu du bruit extérieur
ça vous aurez s'avoue fils quand même
pas mal de choses mais c'est pas aussi
bon que si vous aviez un casque après
c'est assez normal vous êtes quand même
sur des buzz donc j'ai quand même une
partie du son qui va venir ici et qui va
venir autour de votre règle dont vous
êtes pouvoir un peu capter un peu plus
de sons qui viendraient l'extérieur mais
pour des bottes roses que le taf quand
même est vraiment bien fait autre
information vous êtes du bluetooth 5.3
et le alors le truc qui est plutôt bien
ça va vous permettre de venir vous
connecter sur différents appareils en
même temps alex prend une situation de
base vous avez vos écouteurs et vous
êtes sur votre tablette vous écoutez de
la musique vous bossez gens sérieux d'un
coup un coup de fil sonne sans votre
smartphone et bien vous pouvez venir
décrocher directement de pivot buzz et
vous switchez de votre tablette
directement sur votre smartphone il ya
notre cas d' usage qui est vachement
intéressant parce que c'est les tout
premiers bugs qu'on va pouvoir venir
utiliser avec une smart tv de samsung
les tout premiers dont vous regardez la
télé vous êtes le soir vous voulez
déranger personne vous avez mis les buzz
et bien votre téléphone sonne vous
pouvez venir décrocher alors vous avez
pas parlé forte que vous le tournis plus
dérangé personne que vous pouvez le
faire et dès que vous avez raccroché le
paf vous reçoit directement sur votre
télé donc sas en cas d'usagé qui est
aussi intéressant et qui vient faciliter
vraiment la vie de l'utilisateur il
existe également une haute technologie
dont je vais venir vous parler ici on va
être compatibles à 5.1 7.1 et on
également et technologies audio 360
c'est dans l'application jeumont dans
quelques instants la technologie audio
360 les biens lorsque vous allez venir
regarder un film une série sur netflix
pour la musique très clairement je vous
déconseille ça apporte un son beaucoup
plus médium et ça va créer une
spatialisation qui n'est pas naturel et
qui n'est pas jolie en tout cas bon goût
ça ne fonctionne pas vous avez en plus
attendu 360 peuvent bien choisir
d'activer ou de désactiver le fait de
rester dans un axe c'est à dire que
lorsque vous avez par exemple votre
écran en face de vous pouvez venir
activer le fait d'être dans l'axé si
vous tournez la tête leçon restera là ça
peut être marrant pour certains films ça
peut être aussi un peu déstabilisant ça
c'est une option fait le choix de
l'activer ou de ne pas activer
directement dans l'application une fois
de plus on en parle dans quelques
instants vous avez également une autre
option et regardez ce que je vous parle
de l'application va y aller comme ça
vous saurez tout l'application ces
salles là alors pour venir la trouver
c'est très facile il faut que vous
veniez ici et dans votre smartphone vous
allez dans samsung etc l'application
galaxie où elle est belle alors s il ya
un truc à savoir c'est que lorsque vous
prenez vos écouteurs que vous les ouvrez
à côté de votre smartphone de samsung eh
bien ils vont venir sa paire est tout de
suite ils vont venir télécharger
l'application et tout ce dont vous avez
besoin donc là c'est très très facile
totalement transparent donc une fois de
plus vous allez directement dans votre
application ici à méribel et là vous
avez à peu près tous nous être vraiment
vraiment bien fait en fait ce qui est
cool de danse applications c convient
switcher entre les différents appareils
qu'on a un volet vous avez les buzz
promener en bas on voit qu'on a la watch
5 donc je clique là et là j'arrive seul
but du match cinq experts cliquez sont
des bucks deux pros en bas comme ça
j'arrivais j'ai tout alors je vois mon
niveau de batterie ok ça c'est bien le
contrôle du bruit l'âge et de son
environnement parce que je parle parce
que j'ai activé une option et je vais
vous le montrer pour rester en
désactiver là j'entends un peu plus haut
dans des oreilles et la suppression
active de bruit là je m'entends pareil
dans ma tronche c'est chiant donc je
mets le sons environnants alors vous
savez justement cette option que je
retrouvais sur les écouteurs et les
casques de sony et bien c'est le fait de
détecter la voix c'est à dire que
lorsque vous êtes par exemple aux plats
désactivé et que je vais mettre à parler
ça va venir m'activer leçon
environnantes donc ça c'est une petite
option à vous de voir si vous voulez à
faire ou pas par exemple vous êtes dans
la rue vous écoutez de la musique vous
trouvez quelqu'un et salut comment tu
vas pas son environnement première
converser et dès que la conversation est
terminée up savoureux bascule soit
désactivé au soit en suppression de
bruit bon pourquoi pas le doubs 360 je
vous en parlais alors on peut venir est
activé et moi une fois de plus je
conseille vraiment ça pour les films
pour les séries pas pour de la musique
et si vous voulez le suivi des
mouvements tête et bien vous cliquez ici
comme ça vous aurez vraiment ce notre
caution un peu près directive le son
reste là vous tournez votre tête et ça
va switch être plus à l'écouté endroit
là dans l'écouteur gauche je pas si vous
en avez déjà fait l'expérience moi ça
j'aime bien le maître lorsque je me
regarde
petite série ou un film c'est plutôt pas
mal autre chose le contrôle tactile donc
là vous avez vraiment la main par défaut
ça et ça c'était pas activé j'avais
uniquement le fait d'appuyer pour mettre
play pause donc là on préfère choix
d'appuyer deux fois morceau suivant
trois fois morceaux précédents en appui
prolongé pour permuter les côtés du
bruit bon bref voilà faisait quelques
petites options pour les appelle
également à vous de choisir ce que vous
voulez activer ou désactiver c'est très
simple les paramètres des écouteurs y en
a une chiée excusez moi je connais
tellement mais c'est vraiment bien parce
que c'est très très très complet lors
des jalles équaliseur moins de basile et
en normal moi je l'aimé en dynamique je
persiste et je signe en disant que
dynamique ça reste quand même
aujourd'hui la meilleure configuration
alors ce qui est bien c'est que comme on
a une très bonne qualité audio ici eh
bien on va sentir des changements mais
ils sont très légers seydoux et ça évite
d'avoir un truc un peu trop brutale donc
si vous voulez par exemple sont claires
dans l'école isr et fonctionnera en plis
des aigus je suis un peu moins fan
dynamique les basses si vous aimez
vraiment beaucoup de bath mais moi je le
déconseille gêne pas des masses moi ce
que j'aime c'est soit normal si vous
l'écoutez le mix tel qu'il est là de
base ou mettez en normal et vous
désactivez la réduction de bruit ou
alors vous mettez le dynamique et je
trouve que ça vient un peu réhaussé ça
donne un peu plus du coup ça creuse un
peu les médiums parce que ça vient
rehausser les graver une partie des
aigus c'est ce que j'aime bien tout cas
mois à venir écouter ici alors après
vous n'êtes pas mal de choses vous avez
un petit test pour voir s'ils sont bien
ajustés dans vos oreilles vous et pour
vos notifications qu'on peut venir elle
ira vote en fonction des différentes
applications vous allez avoir la dent
vos écouteurs réveil vocal de bixby
leçon environnants pendant vos appels ok
un boeuf il ya pas mal de petites choses
et notamment des trucs qu'ils ont ajouté
c'est le rappel d'étirements du coup
alors ça je vous explique est très
simple vous le prenez vous allez venir
calibré c'est à dire regardez on va se
mettre comme ça incliné la tête jusqu'à
ce que j'entende la sonnerie voilà j'ai
entendu ça vient donc faire un truc qui
est tout simple segal lorsque vous êtes
tout le temps comme ça en train de
regarder des séries entraînerait sur tik
tok compagnie au bout de dix minutes ça
vous dit wouah au fait les étirements
vous vous étirer pour éviter de vous
faire mal et puis d'avoir une mauvaise
posture il ya aussi un petit là bas avec
un mode jeu qu'on peut venir activé sur
le souhaitent voilà il ya plein de
choses dans ses paramètres des écouteurs
et puis ensuite vous avez une petite
fonction localiser mes écouteurs des
pouvoirs bien les localiser si vous les
avez perdu il vous dira tiens voilà la
dernière position connue de vos
écouteurs et si vous partez et que vous
n'avez pas pris vos écouteurs bas vous
ont reçu une information qui vous dire à
vos écouteurs ne font pas avec vous
comme ça pouvait bien aller perret les
prendre il faut venir également partager
la position de vos écouteurs avec des
amis ou des membres de votre famille
odin bastien les écouteurs sont là j'ai
plus sombre est donc voilà ça c'est
plutôt pas mal fichu un petit manuel
donc moi je trouve que cette application
est quand même très complète on fait
plein de choses avec donc ça c'est un
très très beau boulot que nous a fait ça
me sens ici autre truc c'est l'autonomie
à autonomie plutôt intéressante ici on a
une batterie à l'intérieur de 515
méliand paire eur et samsung nous
annonce jusqu'à 29 heures d'écouté avec
vos buzz ce qui est colossal alors je
n'ai pas écouté pendant 29 heures je
n'ai pas mesuré sa comme ça et je n'ai
pas l'information savoir si ces 29
heures avec réduction de bruit active
aussi ses 29 heures sans réduction de
bruit active en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que ces écouteurs va pouvoir
étendre et longtemps avec vous et si
vous avez besoin pour bien les recharges
et bien évidemment à lorsqu'on en
filaire directement la scea plus vite
soit directement son fils ça c'est
plutôt bien d'ailleurs en parlant de la
recharge sans fil je vous parle d'une
offre qui est super intéressante jusqu'à
fin septembre dans quelques instants
pour profiter justement de la changeant
son fils laissez-moi quelques secondes
il faut également savoir qu'elles sont
certifiés ipx est à dire résistant à
l'eau non pas pour les jeter dans une
piscine non pas pour aller se baigner
avec parce qu'il faut pas mais résistant
à la transpiration vous pouvez donc
venir faire du sport avec très
facilement il existe dans différentes
couleurs alors moins la couleur gilles
l'appelle la lavande vous l'avez en
anthracite et en blanc moi j'aime bien
comme ça je trouve ça vachement bien
avec mon galaxy z flip 4 au plat ça
c'est le bon sens la vente on sur ton
c'est joli c'est mignon si je viens à
activer en plus ici la recharge
l'inversé je vais venir recharger les
belges ont passé très pratique et
justement que vous avez une offre du 10
août jusqu'au 30 septembre les crises et
noter juste là si vous venez acheter les
galaxies buzz de pro et bien samsung
vous offre un chargeur due au rapide
sans fil 15 watts de la couleur unique
mans grafite qui est offert donc ces
cadeaux c'est pour vous c'est pratique
quand la police a chargé son fils très
très facilement et ça je vous le dis
c'est jusqu'au 30 septembre prochain je
mets le lien juste en bas dans la
description alors qu'est ce qu'ils
coûtent ces galaxies buzz de pros comme
on dit pro ici on va compter sur le plus
haut de gamme on est à 229 euros c'est
cher c'est un beau budget on est
néanmoins sûre des écouteurs avec une
réduction de bruit active on est sur de
belles innovations donc ça vient
expliquer le tarif même si vous
trouverez des écouteurs en réduction
collective à moins de 100 balles alors
c'est pas la même chose attention
attention il faut vraiment faire
attention parce qu'il faut comparer ce
qui est comparable on parle ici des
meilleurs écouteurs de samsung alors moi
ce que je vais bien aimé sur ce produit
c'est déjà la qualité je trouve vraiment
bonne la réduction proactive et aussi de
très bonne qualité il fonctionnera bien
même si c'est pas la meilleure du marché
j'aime beaucoup tout l'expérience
applicatifs convient retrouver ici
puisque j'aime bien une fois de plus
c'est l'écosystème samsung pourquoi
parce que notamment sur mon galaxy z
flip 4 et bien lorsque je viens écouter
de la musique est bien gardé au plat je
peux mettre lecture ça va venir me
mettre un morceau alors j'écoutais
helloween il ya quelques instants donc
ça c'est cool je peux les avoir
directement là lorsque j'ai en plus ma
galaxie watch ici et bien je retrouve
mon morceau que je peux venir m blake
pause les compagnies dont il ya toute
cette notion d'écosystème qui est
extrêmement importante et qui est
vraiment très très forte chez samsung
qui est super intéressante donc il ya
ces produits qui sont hyper transverse
et le fait en plus qu'il soit pour la
première fois compatible avec une smart
tv de samsung si vous avez une smart tv
de samsung qui vient vous avez pagaille
hier via les intérêts très facilement
pour écouter répondre à un appel bref il
ya ce côté qui est super important est
super intéressante mais qui donne toute
cette valeur ajoutée à samsung alors ces
écouteurs sont bien fondant certains
prix certes mais s'il vous intéresse
vous pouvez y aller je trouve vraiment
bien et par rapport à certains autres
que j'ai pu écouter chez samsung on est
vraiment très très bon donc dites moi ce
que vous en pensez vous en bas en
commentaire est ce que vous pourriez y
aller est ce que vous avez déjà eu des
galaxies buzz de samsung galaxy boeuf
trop peut-être de l'an dernier je me
trouvais aussi plutôt pas mal fichu
dites moi tout ça a bien évidemment
juste en bas dans les commentaires à
l'appui une fois de plus si ce produit
vous intéresse et bien je vous mets un
lien juste en bas dans la description on
se retrouve très très très très bientôt
pour continuer à parler de samsung parce
que là c'est vraiment l'activité très
très chaude on va parler du z philippe
iv je devrais mon retour parce que pour
l'instant je m'amuse bien avec le dreg
allemand mon retour sur la watch cinq
professionnels en parlera également de
la watch 5 on se parlera également du
galaxy z folle 4 que je teste également
en ce moment d'envoyer à plein de choses
qui arrivent c'est très chouette donc si
vous n'êtes pas abonné pensez à vous
abonner actionner la petite cloche pour
identifier dès que la prochaine vidéo
arrivera et ça c'est très bien d'ici là
pour le soin de vous embrasse très fort
et puis des gros bisous et à bientôt
[Musique]
où